so culture is critically important I
would argue to red hat success and we've
worked to build a distinctive culture I
know iBM has been I mean it's a storied
over a hundred year old company with a
really distinctive culture how do you
see those cultures working together
coming together well working together is
the right word coming together is a
difference is not necessary the way I
would describe as Jim and I have talked
this was one of the most important
things because to preserve what open
source is and the value of it it is open
innovation right so all welcome and
therefore so much and you've written a
lot about open so part of what binds us
is the same mission we would both agree
we are on a mission to scale open source
right to scale so that's a good place to
start from when you talk about two
cultures but the next thing and maybe
some people know this I have in Jim and
I both agreed Red Hat should stay an
independent unit now we say well why
would you I thought you knew that
[Laughter]
okay gotcha but well then I'm glad if
people weren't clear on that but there's
really great reasons for that the whole
idea of having a platform that invites
innovation from everyone it means
everyone so you want to have it built on
open source built on open standards you
want any company not just company's
friend coopertition whoever it is so
that that for our clients they can count
on that
and then the terms and conditions of
open source right so all those reasons
the open ecosystem and the only thing we
can help do is help power it to go even
further wider have it have more people
certified etc right you know so think of
that as really broad scale horizontally
so we're both in agreement that stays it
is an independent unit in the work that
really Jim Paul Arun the whole team has
done that you've worked so hard on that
culture and and actually my observation
has been the team's there they work very
well together what we really have these
does they very like-minded on this so
then what's the the other side of this
is that then IBM will change right it's
easier for me to change and to change
IBM in that so much of what Red Hat does
will
build on top of that and hopefully then
what we'll offer to clients is if they
choose a really secure mission-critical
stack a hybrid cloud stack and so
there's a choice or you have a choice to
run at other places but so really
continue and I hope you know together we
take that is it is the world standard of
open around and it's just a bigger and
broader plate for innovation everywhere
you